this evening at about uh just after 11
30 we were called to a bus rollover at
Greta on the highway near cessnock
there we found approximately 37 patients
that were involved in a bus accident
unfortunately that we've had a number of
fatalities a number of seriously ill
patients and we had a number of
resources going from New South Wales
ambulance and other aeromedical we had
six aircraft in total three rescue
trucks with patients being distributed
through John Hunter Maitland Calgary and
and down to Sydney to RPA as I said the
police are investigating it and any of
these matters are always traumatic for
for everyone that attends and especially
for the family involved as well a 58
year old man the driver of the coach was
taken to hospital for mandatory testing
and he's now at cessnock police station
and currently under arrest
I can say that the driver is currently
in the charging process I'm not able to
yet say what those charges are but he is
currently in the charging process and as
soon as we have that information
available we will share that with you
but let me just say it's it's been
complex and I think it's only just now
that the bus has been righted from its
side it's a delicate operation and I'm
sure you can appreciate the need for
that given that people are inside that
bus
foreign